t
tu h
arrête-toi boues un
peu DESS
bouffé
dans l'autre
sens bien que pe le cordon de de to les
cordons on en sur une en fin de compte
tu es où là tu es verticale
ouais spacul quand ça monte ça descend
sur les de tu
vois
ok dis-moi dis-moi on va allerou vas-y
va très bien avance tranquille
tranquille c'est un peu déc je vais y
aller toujours un petit peu en
contrejour toujours un petit peu l'ombre
des dunes sent bien la
dune voilà ça c'est bien c'est
intéressant
ok un plan juste devant toi espèce de
sale avec les voilà toi juste devant toi
voance parce que tu tu ta gauche là
c'est joli ça toi tuas tuas les dunes et
tu as le et tu as trucs j'essay de de
planter autour tu vois en haut à gauche
tu vois
arrête-toioup que je regarde s'il te
plaît plus serré on y va on y va on y
va
dégager
ok cut attends
cutavance
tour
arrête-toi je m'arrêter pas mal ça tout
ça
voilà
ok
coupe to vois c'est bien ça tu vois
voilà tu pe av tu peux bouger un petit
peu la dent tu vois pour faire un peu de
mouvement voilà tu vois on VO là là on
comprend tout cette photo tu vois voilà
tu
vois tois le S qui avance on voit bien
les les fess de voilà doucement voilà
très bien tu vois mon d'autres que ça
super
VO tu bien fait c'est bon pour moi
ça c'est intéressant pour le film en
tout cas
ok Gard Gard
G
ok été bien dire le plan est génial été
bien de faire ce plan là et la ville
derrièreil malheureusement cont mauvais
sensil c'estexliquer que la
ville LTE contre le
désert
je
éce pas
enc0z
oup attendsarde ça vasy tu peux par sur
ta gauche maintenant
tranquilleers la ville
derrière la ville dans soleil
malheureusementil tu c'est
bien
planars la ville je penseon
poseraintenant 10h du matin
ça vaêtre
dur la V est la droite 4 droite 4AD en
hautou voilà tu
voisation voilà c'est bien
voilà
horizon son très Jol c'est làbas alleres
sontes sont à
2h aller par là plus la V
derrière les maisons juste derrière
c'est plus
intéressant contre le
sable
l'intérêt de l'avion c'est qu'on pourra
le faire aller là où il y a du soleil
quoi joli tu
vois il est où là il tourne vers la
droite il va vers où je vois pas très
bien l'ombre hélico en bas à
droite oui alors devant toi la
ville
mon tu
pas